[Musique]
que je
et à l'heure des satellites
les gens sortent
et déjà miné
jour 5 minutes votre terre contre le pot
de fer
traitant qui vend
leur paradis des prix de notre
six morceaux il y en a pas deux qui se
ressemblent ça va du très pêchue comme
quelque chose doit changer au très
sombre comme la plaine où un peu plus
tôt il dit comme le goût des larmes et
voilà et se balader dans ces univers où
nous ont fait les lampes la musicale
aussi parce qu'on aime ça
[Musique]
elles s'en sont imprégnés de cette
ambiance mais aucune ne parle
directement de kobe ou crise sanitaire
ou c'est plutôt s'exprime plutôt des
ressentis dans la situation mais aussi
le ressenti ce sentiment tout vous avez
des gens qu'on aime et c'est déjà
compliqué les aimer toutes ces choses là
en fait qu'on traverse tous
[Musique]
c'est certain que parce que dit le
confinement et parce que nous on est en
tant qu'intermittent dans le spectacle
de spectacle vivant
on est complètement bloquée on peut plus
bouger de chez nous du coup
effectivement là oui ça l'est
ça laisse du temps pour recréer
[Musique]
notre intention si vraiment on veut
reprendre ce que les gens appellent une
vie normale mais surtout une victoire
c'est de peut-être réunir les 3 op dans
un album qui sera physique cette fois ci
ce sera vraiment un cd ou un vinyle
monde hésite encore avec un concert de
sortie et c'est revenir quoi